let's continue with the train of lies
because the thing that really lit this
on fire was that vice president Kamala
Harris the queen of Venn diagrams she
was very upset about this and then she
appeared in Florida here's a little
video of her freaking out about this
thing that's not real a thing we'll get
to that
just yesterday in the State of Florida
they decided middle school students will
be taught that enslaved people benefited
from slavery
they and they Us in an attempt to
Gaslight us and we will not stand for it
okay she's very outraged about what's
going on here so um
look at this I have a piece of paper in
front of me and you're not going to
believe this we've got the actual
information about what's going on here
this is from the National Review I'll
read it to you carefully and you'll get
all of it uh I have been trying to work
out how to best illustrate the sheer
scale of Harris's falsehood and I've
come to the conclusion that the only way
to achieve it is to list in one place
all of the relevant parts of the course
about which she is complaining So Below
I have copied and pasted every single
reference to Slaves the slavery slaves
abolitionism civil rights and African
Americans that is in the document for
those interested the full in the full
curriculum including curriculum for
teaching of the Holocaust is here by the
way as I just said we've linked to it in
our video that you're watching right now
so you can read the entire thing for
yourself there is simply no way of
pursuing of perusing this course and
concluding that it gaslights people or
whitewashes slavery among many many
other things it includes sections on the
conditions for Africans during their
passage to America the living conditions
of slaves in British North American
colonies the Caribbean Central America
and South America including infant
mortality rates the harsh conditions and
their consequences on British American
plantations for example under
nourishment climate conditions infant
and child mortality rates of the
enslaved versus the free the harsh
conditions in the Caribbean plantations
poor nutrition rigorous labor disease
how the South tried to prevent slaves
from escaping in their efforts to end
the Underground Railroad the
overwhelming death rates caused by the
practice the many ways in which Africans
resisted slavery the ramifications of
prejudice racism and stereotyping on
individual freedoms and the struggles
faced by African-American women in the
19th century as it relates to issues of
suffrage business and access to
education many of these modules apply to
Florida specifically so yes Florida is
going all in on teaching reality there
is nothing being whitewashed or anything
else but you guys get it you guys get it
if you do anything
that is remotely against the woke they
will come and try to destroy you and lie
about you and it will be all the way up
from the vice president often it's the
president himself but from the VP to the
harpies at the view to CBS to the
activists online the whole freaking
thing
foreign
[Music]